[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by cash out as you know
cash up is the simplest way to send and
save money and now it's the simplest way
to try to grow your money with cash app
investing I use cash app to pay back
people to pay my openers sometimes just
to hang out with me because I have no
friends and Zack donk ovo sends me ten
dollars every morning I cash up because
it's part of his job description so
that's cool
brokerage services are provided by a
cash app investing is subsidiary of
square and member si PC and as always
when you sign up for cash up and use the
promo code Congrats not only will you
instantly receive $10 but cash up will
also now donate $10 to the trevor
project an amazing organization that
provides crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to LGBTQ youth
across America download cash app from
the App Store or Google Play Store today
[Music]
dude that's a new song for mr. green
it's a remix it's not the new song I
mean it is a new ish song it's a remix
it's like mr. green made it for us he
made all the all the music for us and it
changes every now and then and he just
texted me over one recently and as luck
would have it at pop so you know as luck
as luck would have it it [ __ ] it pops
so we played it for you my babies and
that's what's up
we got the eagle up today chillin maybe
getting a sign made so we'll see dude
but I got a casino rama coming up these
are some tour dates Chris Chris Thalia
shows coming up technically the
follow-the-leader tour is over so I'll
probably be doing maybe some of the
stuff from it at this casino rama i
might just do it the whole tour the
whole hour there at this casino rama
thing on January 17th and January 18th
that's an hour outside of Toronto its
Aurelia Irvine California I'm working on
some newer stuff along with some of the
older stuff that's all sold out January
the 23rd weekend not trying to brag but
it's all sold out I don't know if the
ice house is all sold out February 7th
and 8th West Palm Beach Florida I'll be
there March 20th 2022 March 21st I think
there's still some tickets left cuz that
club is about [ __ ] 4,000 seats
Robinson Ville Mississippi Rohnert Park
California Las Vegas I got some dates
coming up and I'm working on some more
dates I think I'm working on Brea and
stuff like that but anyway come see me
Chris D'Elia live in the flesh and and
you can and you can do that I am I've
got some other news that I'm working on
that could be announced soon and
other than that dude chillin
honestly chillin I have been in town
it's been really rocking at the Comedy
Store lately man I've been working on
this new material and I'm very happy
about it and it's been really rocking at
the Comedy Store
it's been good at the Laugh Factory I
haven't played The Improv too much
recently but I need to get back over
there actually after this week in what
do you call it
Toronto outside of Toronto I'm gonna be
going to by the way Toronto's the number
one [ __ ] place where they're like hey
you know you never come to Toronto dude
that really grinds my [ __ ] gears when
someone says you never come dude I last
week somebody says hey when you come
into Chicago literally just played
14,000 seats okay so he that should just
you know that'll never ever end I talked
about it with my agent Sal Hollywood but
that'll never end do it we always talk
about how like whenever you whenever I
leave there's always somebody they
wouldn't come into blank and I was just
there but it's all good
anyway I'm chillin dude I'm [ __ ]
chillin I'm happy I got a new mattress
so it's [ __ ] killer
I slept in it Zonk the [ __ ] out you did
the math dude you ever Zonk out man uh I
try everything from a restless legs i
got restless-leg syndrome you know what
it is it's something I would think is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
except for have it I would think
restless leg is [ __ ] cept have it so
it [ __ ] feels like an electrical and
I got these PowerPoint things that I put
on my my legs and then I put them on my
legs and then they [ __ ] zap them and
I don't know if it helps but whatever I
tell you what I put it on my story and
people so many people are like does this
work I don't even know what you mean
does it work what does it mean when
people that's one of the things I really
got to get behind his massages and like
muscle work and [ __ ] everybody's telling
me it's a very la thing I don't know if
it's around everywhere but people like
you got to make sure
or the recovery you massage the [ __ ] out
and how do you there's no there's no
like what do you call it
central what do you call that [ __ ]
thing there's no central how do you you
can't compare it to something else do
you know I'm saying like if you're so I
guess if you work out both legs at the
same time then they get equally a sore
and then your only muscle work you
[ __ ] massage one leg then the next
day you see if that leg feels better
than the other leg right that's the
control that's what I'm looking at
that's the control the control Jesus
Christ dude got a DNA job right yes does
it matter it doesn't matter at [ __ ]
all what you get in algebra unless
you're gonna be an algebra trician dude
one time one time I was I was doing
algebra in my in my [ __ ] high school
class and and I was like and my mom was
like you really gotta work harder on
algebra it's hard I just never made any
sense
I had a [ __ ] teacher named Mrs Weaver
and I was getting addy and we have to
make it we have to make it I have I had
to do better and I was trying to do
better trying to do better and then all
of a sudden they introduced imaginary
numbers and I [ __ ] straight-up said
in my head go [ __ ] yourself dude
imaginary numbers know all the shit's
imaginary you got eight apples and then
eight apples walk in the door and guess
what there's no [ __ ] apples though
did you know that you're making it all
up
these are all problems you're making up
ok you want to know the most [ __ ]
Asian thing you can do if you're an
American Asian is this playing with your
pen and doing tricks with your pen like
that everyone in LA cañada all the
American Asians would do this [ __ ] and
they'd [ __ ] catch it and I [ __ ]
learned how to do that in algebra and I
can [ __ ] still do it and I'm not even
[ __ ] 40 I know but when I get older
dude I'm gonna [ __ ] always be like
twirling it like this
oh wow such a [ __ ] anyway dude
imaginary numbers bro no no I wish
that's the thing I wish I was me now
back then and I know people like to
think like I know how people everyone
knows it I wish I knew back then what I
know now dude I don't even care about
knowing the [ __ ] I wish I was more out
spoken because I was that dude back then
- I had all the opinions but I just
[ __ ] didn't really revel in it
I needed to I need to be in algebra now
as a 17 year old and I need Mrs Weaver
to be saying oh so these are introducing
imaginary numbers and then I go like
this no they're all imaginary you making
up all these problems by none of this
[ __ ] exists dude and if you listen to
this and you're 17
first of all turn it off cuz imma Badham
cuz mmm bad influence but also now
algebra [ __ ] sucks dude and I'm
almost 40 and I'm telling you that now
you know how they're like well when you
get older you know you don't do it and
I'm not a bad influence dude [ __ ] this
man I'm telling you right now you high
school kids get out of that algebra
class due to high school is you got to
do it because they gotta figure out how
to make it so kids don't [ __ ] stab
each other and do heroin you understand
that's what high school is so all the
kids just kind of chill out hang out
learn how to be with each other that's
why I call it college is too early
everyone should go to college when
they're 26 27 28 that's when you because
that's the thing it's everyone's
you're not done develop I'll tell you
what I was immature kid until I was 33
or 34 I was a late bloomer
for real I went through puberty a little
bit late and I was not an adult until I
was 34 35 I did immature [ __ ] was
selfish as [ __ ] that's the thing dude 18
you want me to go to college at 18
that's why when everyone goes to 18 it
goes to college at 18 they go absolutely
bonkers men all of a sudden the dorky
kid is the cool kid you ever had you
know that [ __ ] it's like a a [ __ ] you
come back for this spring for the summer
break or spring break and they're like
hey we're all going to [ __ ] Roberts
house Robert Robert who Robert Dallman
what yeah the [ __ ] kid was a dork bro
he runs Pepperdine
what are you kidding me
are you kidding are you kidding me bro I
went to visit him in Mizzou haha that
guy who runs it dude
he's practically Chris Brown at Mizzou
what he wear the [ __ ] trench coat bro
he doesn't wear that anymore
he's got green hair that's not cool
where do you see him bro it's pretty
poppin and then he shows up with like
[ __ ] some chick named hailey and
you're like oh she's from [ __ ] st.
Francis
she's from the other school god this
guy's poppin and now everybody wants to
be friends with [ __ ] Rob that's
because we all go to college too or too
early
Rob didn't even figure out what the [ __ ]
he was til he went to Mizzou and now
it's on and poppin in the mother time
that yeah
can people change I hated that [ __ ] I
was who I was in high school bro
and now I am Who I am and that shit's
not change in dude it's funny dude how
that happens though we all go we we go
away and then we become who we become
that's dude I tell a man I have bothered
me man when I was a kid like people will
go study abroad and they'd come back and
[ __ ] and they'd be like yeah [ __ ]
girls would be like lost my virginity
and dudes would be like took a backpack
walked around a little bit read a book
no I know how nine know how it goes
check in with me we're all lost we're
all [ __ ] lost man
we go to college too early that's why
now there's people with like [ __ ] you
know you see that guy walking a bird
with flying that guy it's cuz he went to
college too early you said that guy
thing on Twitter he was running down the
street with two parrots on a leash and
the parrots were flying and he was
running with those parrots that guy
should get all the [ __ ] and I'm not
joking girls that guy deserves all of it
for real don't even know what he looks
like
but he's gangster if I were like that if
I was a guy
I got a walk Birds man I gotta walk
Birds do you know I didn't know you
could walk Birds you know what I'm
talking about right you guys have seen
this [ __ ] the birds are flying the guys
are running okay I didn't know you could
walk Birds bro I never even thought of
that this guy is living in 2050 the
birds are level two birds are they [ __ ]
how come we don't talk about how cool
birds are men but unless you're Bryan
Callen we got to all start get we gotta
stuff that's what that's the thing about
high school is that the classes are all
the classes because they need to figure
out the basic they need to all conform
to all of the certain types of people I
didn't like that [ __ ] because I'm not
doing the [ __ ] that everyone does cuz I
you know why don't wanna don't wan okay
so that's why if I was remember
electives and [ __ ] you'd be like well
I'd like to get into a home Eric I'd
like to even those were [ __ ] I'm
talking about dude when I was soon as
you get out eighth grade I should have
been able to sign up for [ __ ] bird
walk in class and and and there should
have been a stand-up comedy class or
whatever the [ __ ] and not even a class a
stupid class to have but like some kids
want to be a magician I want to be a
magician so now what oh well there's no
magician class okay so at least let's
just have the teacher's guide the people
and try to learn some magic to teach to
the kids that's why I like David Blaine
he doesn't even really do mine he does
magic but also hope you like I'll just
stand in a spot for seven weeks and
you're like oh well that's not magic
music but I'm testing my body
you're like Kay I agree you test in your
body I can just break out of these
handcuffs really yeah wow that's amazing
it takes eight weeks
oh so you just keep on trying to break
them in and finally this is wear and
tear and then open yeah okay is it magic
I'm testing my body okay but he can do
card tricks to my babies so saw him do
our card tricks to Al Pacino and that's
a real story I live in a fantasy I saw
David Blaine do a [ __ ] card trick to
Al Pacino and Guy Fieri was there and so
Fester Stallone was filming it I live in
a fantasy and then and then and then and
then did David Blaine say to Al Pacino
pick a suit and then did Al Pacino say
well I was in Armani the other day ah I
live in a fantasy now Pacino turned to
me and he said remember that card I live
in a fantasy Al Pacino turned over to me
and said there's my card
remember it and then I said well I will
net I will actually never forget any of
this in my life
okay was the seven of diamonds so anyway
that's crazy
so mm-hmm well you know the high school
should be more specific that's why it's
specific you gotta get specific high
schools man there should be clumps of
high schools that are like for certain
things like the entertainment high
schools that they have sometimes they
have like some of them in Texas or some
[ __ ]
dance high schools they got those weird
ones I used to think those were [ __ ]
weird but they're probably right what if
you know you love animals and you want
to go to a [ __ ] sanctuary high school
like an animal sanctuary high school and
just chill with [ __ ] zebras and
Gophers loved the dude that would I
hated that when I was in when I was in
elementary school and the guy would come
with all the animals
Oh everyone loved it well it's animal
day we get to come out the guy comes
with animals and if you like got class
this is a gopher and Steven de Filippis
would be like uh-oh and there'd be some
kid [ __ ] with a closed throat because
a gopher came out like
sorry Matthews [ __ ] allergic he's got
to go home now
in the 80s nobody gave a [ __ ] now come
bring animals I wonder if they still do
that they probably don't they used to
bring [ __ ] snakes out dude hey they
could kill us like why not just bring a
wild boar
oh yeah it's snake up theirs is up the
snake swallowed Tommy we didn't like him
anyway dude why not just bring a wild
boar bring a hyena
they should just bring a [ __ ] imagine
them bringing just a starving hyena hey
class gather around it's just like this
hyena oh whoa it's thrashing oh whoa
whoa
okay it has Danny Vic's arm whoa it's
thrashing Danny Vic's arm
hey da swallow man die hit I swallowed
my arm um anyway my [ __ ] one time I
was at a strip club when I was 21 dude
and my friend was there and he was 20
and he went up to the [ __ ] brawl I
know I don't go up to the stage I chill
back like a mob boss when I go to the
strip club haven't been in a long time
but when I go I sit back like a mob boss
man you think I don't cross my legs at
the strip club Oh bro you're crazy man I
cross one leg over my [ __ ] onto my
[ __ ] leg I'm real British at the
strip club dude but I'm also an Italian
mobster dude and I lay back and I sip a
[ __ ] club soda or nothing dude I
gotta feel good in my environment one of
the reasons why I don't smoke is cuz I
didn't need to [ __ ] I don't want to
have to do [ __ ] I don't when I take a
break I want you to know I'm taking a
break
I don't want oh he's got to go do
something no no no no dude I straight-up
gotta get away if I'm at a party which I
never am if I'm at a party and some
shits going on and I gotta take a break
I go outside and I wait do it I feel it
in my body I used to be uncomfortable
taking a break I didn't have a cigarette
I wasn't checking my cell phone they
weren't around cellphones rolling around
and now cell phones are around sometimes
I took my cell phone but you best
believe I could just take a break
sit outside and wait with my hands in my
pockets people like what's he doing just
staring at the sky man that's a break
I'm not fidgety dude I'm not fidgety I
learned that from my dad he just chills
and that's the thing I so I would go to
the strip club and sit back like a mob
boss dude and then in the end on the on
the on the stage some people would go
walk up to this stage and sit at the
stage and one time my friend he was 20 I
was 21 he was 20 he walked up to this
stage and he put his feet which is like
his face was all up in it and the girl
was dancing it around like that and she
was like squeezing her boobs and stuff
said juvenile and by the way what word
do you use for tits to not sound like a
[ __ ] creep
for real tits boobs I'm 39 tit if I say
yeah her tits were good I seem like a
creep if I say yeah her boobs what am i
12 what do you say jugs you sunk a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not I mean
breasts then you sound like what are you
doing you're trying not to sound like a
creep which makes it creepier so what
the [ __ ] is it come up with some [ __ ]
Tatas then you're just an [ __ ] you
know what I mean like cringe I'm gonna
say [ __ ] boo boo boo boo boo Belize
that's what I'm gonna say yeah yeah did
you see her [ __ ] boo boo Belize at
least then I'm [ __ ] owning it bro
Boboli Oh Belize Looby loo
that's what I'm gonna find anyway we're
at the strip club and he/she was [ __ ]
working it this was before torque and
she was just regular work in it not to
work in it
and she was just moving her [ __ ]
booby luby's around and just [ __ ]
holding him the booby Lube isn't sitting
around and [ __ ] gyrating and [ __ ] and
I'm sitting back in a mob boss like I
had a cigarette but I did it okay I was
just chilling being me being inside me
you understand reveling in it I was my
body inside my body
you understand I'm a [ __ ] author and
I was watching my buddy going like this
his face so close to boobie luby's right
and he was and she was doing the thing
and she brings her boobie luby's over to
him and I see it from afar okay like am
i bus and I I see some [ __ ] go down and
then he backs up a little bit casually
and then he walks over to me and my
other buddy who I was with and my other
buddy was a really tall big guy that has
nothing to do with this story but I want
you to know a little bit about the
surroundings so he walks up to me and
this guy was a little guy and that has
nothing to do with the story but I want
you to understand the color of the scene
he walks up to me and something's wrong
okay now I know something's wrong
because I know my friend but I also know
something's wrong because you don't
[ __ ] sit at the stage at the strip
club especially alone now he walks up to
me and he says guys I don't know what to
say and I don't know I had to say it and
we leaned forward like yes because we
want to hear it because we want to die
of laughter and he says but it's true
she scored it
breast milk in my in my at my nose and
it dripped in my mouth a little bit
that's what he said dude that's the
sentence he said and I never forgot it
she squirted her breast milk on my nose
and it caught in my mouth a little bit
and that was a sentence said and never
forgot it
there's only before or after that moment
in my life and there's only before or
after that moment in his coz he drank
not his mom's breast milk and dude we
fell out me and the big guy we fell out
our mob-boss chillin was all tattered we
fell out we were again 12 and then the
best part was he told us after she did
it he squeezed it like a [ __ ] like
his fruit and it shot out his nose I
went into his mouth a little bit
and dude she she after that she goes
like this
and did a [ __ ] finger up to his thing
her her mouth like she like he was like
he was talking at the lot in the library
like it was a treat for him hey lady
don't squirt milk in my nose especially
if it comes from your body be AUD bye
dude
kinky not a turn-on then we told it to
another one of our buddies later and he
was like I think I'd like that okay and
we were like what bro
I don't know it kind of turned me on
once I was with a girl who was recently
a mom and and mil and I drank it a
little bit out of her and him kind of
turned me on and I was like
drive-by [ __ ] single shot at it
wasn't even a [ __ ] automatic from an
automatic rifle ah it was a dude are you
kidding me what the [ __ ]
ah God dude
strip club shenanigans so funny man ah
do you sell stuff online sir fired
shipstation
do you sell stuff online when you're
probably look then you're probably still
recovering from that crazy holiday
shopping season you know how it was it
was not so well I have a way to help you
make twenty twenty a lot less crazy and
a lot more successful
it's called ship station ship station
makes managing and shipping out orders a
breeze import orders from any sales
channel ship with any carrier using are
deeply discounted rates do you hear that
automat automate just about any shipping
task with ship station you'll spend less
time on shipping and more time growing
your business which is what's important
I use ship station for all my merch
people tweet me how fast they get their
merch two days later even one day later
if you're selling something you need
this I'm making the choice for you it's
already done my babies get this year off
to a great start at ship station calm
just use my offer code congrats to get a
60 day free trial that's two months free
of no hassle stress free shipping just
visit ship station dot-com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in Congrats
that's ship station comm enter offer
code Congrats
ship station make ship happen me undies
love is in the air someone grab the
Lysol just can't
even though this is a made-up holiday
it's still really cute it's also the
perfect time to show that special
someone how much you care and say those
three words everyone wants to hear match
my undies my undies has the most
adorable Valentine's Day prints to get
all lovey-dovey this year bro you want
to be cute do you want to be cute then
don't worry use me undies and if you
don't have a boo me undies also makes
buddy bands so you can match with your
pet which is honestly more important
than people and that's cute too and if
you don't have a loved one and you don't
have a dog get the regular kind
I love missing my undies they're so
comfortable that's all I wear that's all
good too much oh how much they love you
me undies has not one but three new
Valentine's Day princess here you got to
go check them out do it now
me undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15% off and free shipping this
is a no-brainer especially because they
have a 100% satisfaction guarantee to
get you 15% off your first pair of free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me on DS calm / Congrats that's me
undies dot-com / congrats anyway dude
how fun is that breast milk thing man
squirting I wonder if he remembers that
I gotta ask him about that he used to
wear shirts that say [ __ ] have a
golden day and he used to piss me off
you know so how's that for a [ __ ]
golden day bro almost got a [ __ ]
golden shower so juvenile
one time I was at a strip club let's see
the other strip clubs one time I was at
a strip club dude I was probably 19 I
read the first time I went to a strip
club my buddy Warren took me in
Vancouver and I was like I never been to
a strip club he's like we got to go
buddy so we went and there was a girl
that looked like had there graham that
was a stripper and I was like wow and
she was naked and I was like wow
dude this is amazing and they would give
massages and [ __ ] just like on your back
while you were watching Vancouver
Canadians I think probably I don't
really know but I think probably
Canadian strip clubs rip you probably
can't do kind of is crazy because it's
like still kind of America ish but it's
also a little bit got a little bit of a
European vibe so that people are like
yeah but what's wrong with being naked
and you're like really okay boy y'all
y'all young yeah what's what's wrong
with like just probably some park where
you could take your [ __ ] top off in
Canada somewhere up north north you know
and you're like what the [ __ ] is this
bracket kack kack you know hey good
thing I have a place to hang my coat now
cuz it's freezin and that's on your
boner people say it's not funny to
explain jokes but it is dude you just
got to do it in the right way
hey bracket got got good thing there's a
place to hang my coat now and that's
because I have a bow zero I loved um man
it's so funny man I bet guys at strip
clubs think they're the [ __ ] you ever
see a guy walk into a strip club
there's two guys that walk into strip
club there's either the guy that walks
in that's like I shouldn't be here what
do I do I'm nervous or there's the guy
that's like playing it up that's just
like hey what's up this is my [ __ ]
this is my room now you guys you guys
could all leave um I don't know my core
is all [ __ ] sore because my my I did
this class legree where they used that
[ __ ] mega former they had the
reformer for the Pilates you used the
reformer Legree was like none [ __ ]
that reformer we've got that mega former
and so I was doing it in the class and I
was going up to a [ __ ] point on the V
bro and I did that so many times that
now my core is a really sore and then I
tried to do [ __ ] weighted pull-ups 26
pounds on my belt I could do eight of
them bro
I can do eight of them you understand
and I did six exit sets of that and my
core was on fire because you work at
core when you do pull ups to roam in
tip-top shape got to got to lean it out
a little bit though you know got to lean
it out a little bit anyway I have too
many beakers when I was a kid I decided
that beauty marks were called beakers
and I would just say beakers to my mom
and my mom would be like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
I'll be like mom why do I have beakers
and she's like huh and it'd be like
these things and she laughed like hell
she was like that's not a beaker and I
was like well what is it she's like a
beauty mark or a skin tag and I was like
now we call it a beaker sprout also when
I was a kid I thought the word except
was Incept
and I and I wanted it to be incept and
my dad would say you know the words
except exc EPT and I'd say it should be
in cept I said the [ __ ] when I was eight
I was like it should be in cept because
it's instead of that you're using this
okay and my dad's like and my dad said
yeah you're actually right and that's a
good dad and I can't wait to tell my son
all the rules dude if my son do you
understand if my son if it's one of his
first things are in Sept I don't want to
I do understand I start crying because
I'm happy that's the [ __ ] dude when my
son says in some teaching them in cept
and when my son says in cept
Oh plan victim music why did I [ __ ]
come up with that thing about how
what's-his-name was four foot tall
what's his name a con a con so close to
a corn um I want my name to be close to
isn't he British he it makes so much
sense that he would be so [ __ ] poppin
in Britain dude Akon looks so British
oh he's 511 alright that's not bad he's
not even short literally just made that
up one podcast guy cool it's so funny to
think of people shorter though so that's
what I do
nah I'm gonna meet a con one day and be
like now you [ __ ] guru bro I do
groose inside I know in [ __ ] 2018 you
were shorter can't believe people
listened this podcast but it's bigger
than ever my babies dude we get so many
[ __ ] views and listens now it's off
the charts you know what that means
packs are you guys enjoying the show you
I did you that show I played a creep
called Henderson and let's talk about it
a little bit you know when you're on a
show a real show like I've done a lot of
comedy shows but when you're in a real
show with real acting and real actors
and good actors and good production and
good writers and [ __ ] and people that
give a [ __ ] about it you know it's so
funny to be a comedian on one of those
shows cuz look people are I'm really
happy that people are liking what I did
you know a lot of people are saying a
lot of really positive things about my
performance and I really appreciate that
and I want you to know something I know
I know I know I'm gonna go in there and
[ __ ] do it at least okay okay do you
know why I know cuz I got a good head on
my shoulders alright I'm not gonna go in
and [ __ ] some [ __ ] up yeah I played in
the scene where he had to torture me and
[ __ ] stab my arms a little bit and
I'm really getting into that
[ __ ] dude do you understand I
don't act I'm not [ __ ] dude I'm not
gonna act in it I'm I'm a [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] you understand I sit there
and I think okay dude I'm getting
tortured let's do this [ __ ]
you understand I'll cry right now dude
I'm I don't these mother [ __ ] where
do I put okay so if I walk it actors is
what actors do so if I walk in all right
you want me to grab the thing see that's
the thing I got to grab the phone and
walk over here that's what happens when
a director says hey could you maybe say
that over here that's what happens when
an actor gets that note oh you got it
good oh okay I got well let me uh if I
go over there though then I need to take
the phone because the phone and you want
me to already have the phone over here
then that's bro no no no no when a
director says hey could you say that
over there I go like this okay and I do
the [ __ ] and if it doesn't match in the
[ __ ] that's your problem bro
I don't ask these questions cuz I'm
really doing it bro I'm gonna ask it
about props can you put the shirt on
sure fine did it make sense in the Edit
I don't give a [ __ ] I'm here to do you
know look at this article go scroll up
is Henderson from you based on a real
person Chris D'Elia plays an awful do it
[ __ ] yeah I do cuz they asked me you
know oh it's the the two dumbest things
that people are oh I get involved bro
when I do it when I do it I seen I get
involved man
you understand me dude you'll never see
me act bad dude
you won't [ __ ] see it okay so so I
was in so the two things that people are
saying what the [ __ ] is Krista Leah
doing in you bro actin man that's how I
do it and here's the other one
hey Krista Leah keeps playing a [ __ ]
pedophile twice name another time dude
two times I played a pedophile once in
you and the other when I was on the show
Whitney and that's [ __ ] dude you
can't name the one
it's that's so annoying when people say
that because dude somebody wrote do you
intentionally play pedophiles or do you
what hey
what they asked me to be in the [ __ ]
thing I like the part so I said yeah I
can't all I'm trying to do is get to the
point where I can be an action star and
then also in the end of my career like
the Liam Neeson years I can play a
Japanese guy with no makeup that's my
dream bro is to [ __ ] up the internet and
just play a Japanese guy with no makeup
and have people just ir8 about it well
why didn't they get a real Japanese got
to do that well because crystally is a
big star you know when I'm 60 and we
thought he was going to get the [ __ ]
box office and I did because and I want
to get nominated for a Golden Globe and
that's it no Oscar do it just the Golden
Globe and not win and all they do is
straight my hair no makeup and I barely
use an accent cuz I'm so subtle dude and
I'm not acting while I'm filming I'm
Japanese you are what you say are anyway
so what the [ __ ] it matter I got to do
more ads
kaptara New Year bigger goals get the
big things done the better faster and
easier way in 2020 with kaptara
it's the free website millions of people
use monthly to find software for the
business kaptara simplifies the software
search to just a few easy steps first
identify the software features you need
then use the Smart Search tool plus
filters to find the right software for
your industry save your favorites to a
shortlist and compare them side-by-side
find your best choice at kaptara comm
slash podcast kaptara is the free online
resource millions used monthly to find
the best software solution for the
business kaptara helps your business
thrive by making the software buying
process easy and effective and doing it
as much as much as they can as possible
and it's amazing educating you on how to
get the most out of your software tools
and services before and after buying
over 1 million reviews from real
software users discover everything you
need to make an informed decision it's
great 700 specific categories of
software visit kaptara comm slash
podcast for free today to find the tools
to make an informed software decision
for your business kaptara comm podcasts
kaptara that's Capt RR a.com slash
podcast kaptara software selection
simplified congratulations brought to
you by cash up the official app of the
log cabin yeah do it a lot of actors
will be like you know they'll be like
can you move this and then can you say
this over here and then an actor will be
like because acting isn't very hard
they'll be like well how do I get there
over there if my the thing is over here
and I gotta grab it over here and then I
don't feel motivated to know I want to
get to a point in my career where I
could just be like doing that with like
a high class actor and the high class
actor doing that I'm just like hey man
just do it it's gonna be fine ha ha I'm
a nice guy
I really am a nice guy on set too
they got almonds on the craft service
I'll [ __ ] eat almonds like I'm pretty
like I pretended like like almonds when
I'm on set that's how I do it I
pretended like almonds so much I [ __ ]
eat so many almonds for a guy who
[ __ ] hates almonds I eat so many
almonds almonds suck dude
almonds tastes like goddamn you know
what almonds tastes like a computer
that's what they taste like they're just
regular as [ __ ] that's a real food huh
um yeah so my score is all solid you
know I got to start doing this [ __ ] more
my buddy's trying to hang with this
chick and he's got he's he's in the
friend zone man and he did it to himself
yes he did it to himself
yes and this guy's like how do I get out
of the friendzone Lucayan baby whoa if a
girl put you in the friend zone you can
maybe get out if you put yourself in a
friend zone that's like putting on an
astronaut suit and saying why are we
going to the moon you did it yourself
baby yes you're in there man you forgot
the key and you locked yourself in whoa
dude how do I get out of the friendzone
should I make a move now he said that's
like taking off your [ __ ] space
helmet and take a hammer break the glass
you can't breathe because that's how it
knows let me make a move oh yeah I've
been texting our paragraphs dude never
text anyone an indention never text
anyone tab over this guy writes enter
space make space a space just hey dude
are you Sora Neale Hurston spell you
you don't spell it why you because then
the girl knows you care that's 101 okay
this guy how do I get out of the
friendzone
well you don't dude you don't the best
you could do is chill in the friendzone
and hope that that girl hope that our
life unravels cuz that's the only chance
you got baby is being the shoulder to
cry on and then all of a sudden that
turns into some real [ __ ] you've got no
[ __ ] chance bro ah you know what I
say friendzone shman zone dude and I've
been saying that [ __ ] you gotta meet a
girl and you gotta [ __ ] be like I
don't know man one time I did an
interview and it girls like how do you
get a girl and I said you asked him if
they have a boyfriend and she was like
really and I said yeah you have a
boyfriend and she goes haha that's it
baby
well she got uncomfortable I kissed a
microphone though uh you gotta shake
things up man
like being in the friendzone is the
least sexy thing ever it's sexier to
walk up to a girl look in her face and
go hey I farted and then pivot like in a
swivel way like do a Justin Timberlake
move out that's so sexy dude to walk up
to a girl and say hey by the way hands
in your pockets hey just want you to
know I farted and then I'll sure it
I do an usher move out and just be
[ __ ] singing these are my confessions
being in it don't ain't ain't a no Nate
do you know how I swear to God if you
have the utmost confidence if you could
max if you could get them confidence at
Mach 10 if you could [ __ ] 99th
percentile that confidence to say hey
babe no as a matter of fact say tits hey
toots I farted and then do a spin move
these are my confessions Blaine anta
don't they in a nail don't think that
girl needs a towel let me let me [ __ ]
one shot it out for you here dude that's
a single shot
excuse me barista can I get a single
shot yeah bro uh sure with the mic that
comes down from his ear Sabet use a
regular microphone give a [ __ ]
unless you're Bill Bellamy in the 90s
trying to put his jacket on without
[ __ ] using his hands that's how I
sure dances trying to take his clothes
off without using his fingers enhance
that's how I sure dances and everyone
knows it
and usher knows it and that's it
look this video is called the best
dancer uh sure such a [ __ ]
non-american thing that that was written
the best dancer uh sure is the most
foreign thing ball down to four words
yeah baby
ah anyway uh that's that's what's up
you got to learn how to if you can get
to that confidence level if you can get
to that confidence level of telling a
girl or anybody dude in a business
meeting if you want a [ __ ] job and
you could there is a way if you're in
the matrix if you're hooked in and you
know about the matrix to walk into a
[ __ ] job and say hey well how are you
nice so you're applying for this job and
you say yep and you got your hands in
your pockets and the person sitting
there what are your strengths and
weaknesses well I'll tell you my
strengths and they say yes mr. D'Elia or
whatever your name is
in my case it's that you get up off the
chair keep your hands in your pockets
lean over the desk and say well I
shouldn't ate that many bananas earlier
because I keep farting and then pivot
and usher away you get the job I
guarantee you only if you are in the
99th percentile of confidence that's it
you got to be Mach 10 on the confidence
scale or you say something like I
invented the term boobie luby's and that
means tits and then you walk out and you
drive and you drive a golf cart away Wow
if you drove a golf cart to the [ __ ]
ha ha ha you understand I would hire a
guy immediately Wow god I wish I was
[ __ ] Harry in the royal family I wish
I was him how are they being so how are
how is anybody in the royal family not
doing using their experience to the
fullest like seriously if I was in the
royal family I would do [ __ ] like only
wear shorts no matter where the [ __ ] I
was are you kidding me
CNN Fox News bustle everyone would be
doing articles about me why is he only
wearing shorts I would do so many
interviews because that's how I want to
dress I'm the [ __ ] Prince are you
kidding me why do have an eyepatch on
cuz I only want to see out of one our
today
you [ __ ] bollocks Oh far Edie these
are my confessions meaning it not no no
no not my night
so British singing it Harry's out of the
royal family that's so weird
that's kind of cool though but also like
what are you doing where they gonna move
back to where they're gonna move LA you
know what is this a [ __ ] NBC show he
was British and now it was in the royal
family and now moved out to LA she's
gonna try acting again uh-oh it's the
prince new on NBC oh no one what is this
what is this everything is organic what
is happening what is going on
everybody's cars like look sighs from
the future what's going on
but yeah don't text anyone paragraphs
seriously I mean that it's so annoying
people hate that what are you doing do
is what you have to say important well
then guess what just think it that's for
you
but yeah I don't know about this Harry
and Megan thing I mean they'll finally
[ __ ] hates Megan right now because
also dude isn't she like half black or
something I bet I bet the black British
people right now are like oh alright
okay well we had it for a second
oh boy alright alright oh I know it was
too good to be true
yes sir alright [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't know about this they might live
in North America wait was it Prince
Harry who got Megan her Disney deals
she's got a Disney deal uh what the [ __ ]
is going on anymore you know I love how
you know what I love this week is how
Sharon Stone got [ __ ] kicked off a
bumble because everyone thought she was
fake cuz why the [ __ ] is Sharon Stone on
bumble dude internet dating is crazy I
was talking about it with my friends
last night I've never done any sort of
internet dating I've never been on the
thing I was thought like when it came
out I was like it felt like you know I
was like a little bit of an old head
like a that's kind of corny I don't want
to be doing that I should be meeting
people in real life I know if actually
thought that it was a long time ago but
I never did it and then I was like I
started to get a little bit of like I
was on TV and stuff it was like well I
can't do it now cuz it'll just be so
weird people be like why is this guy on
this thing and then I found out that
like Pauly Shore was on it and I was
like oh well [ __ ] if Pauly Shores on
it then I guess that's so weird but I
guess it doesn't really matter anymore
and then everybody was on it like I
heard [ __ ] like good actors were on it
and [ __ ] and like magicians and like BMX
guys and I was like are maybe you could
get on it and I just never got or I
always had a girlfriend or something and
I was never on the dating app and now
[ __ ] Sharon Stone is on it
how old is Sharon Stone by the way she's
still so hot huh well she's 61 she looks
great huh I went on bumble dating site
and they closed my account some users
reported that it couldn't possibly be me
hey bumble is me is being me
exclusionary don't shut me out of the
hive I didn't even know Sharon Stone was
on Twitter um
[Music]
Sharon Stone was and is so hot and she's
good too
she's a star you know that's what a star
is right there so people are just stars
some people are just stars even if
they're not famous they're stars
No
I thought was like that Pete Davidson it
was just a star you know it's just like
a guy that's just like a star he's not
ever gonna go away he's always gonna be
poppin there's gonna be something you
know he got a little bit of hate because
of ariana grande when that [ __ ] went
down the dudes just a star man there's
just something about him that you want
to [ __ ] look at a lot of people are
like that
well not Timothy shell MA he's like that
Sharon Stone's like that who else is
like that it's funny dude yes yeah I
don't think rushers like that that dudes
a big star but he's just like a guy that
learned at all he's gonna have that
[ __ ] he doesn't have that [ __ ]
quality that just is just star you know
very talented um who else has that [ __ ]
it's not about being famous either who
else do you treated to me who you think
has that I won't read it and I also
don't care what you think but make sure
you do that yeah I stop that's one of my
I don't really have resolutions but I
was sitting around and I was like I was
talking with my girl and I was like dude
I got to stop reading a lot of these
Twitter comments sorry but a lot of you
guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] so I'm gonna
stop doing that be nicer you know that's
it
I guess we're pretty much done here I
won the tea I already talked about this
the fighter of the year I'm the kid I'm
the winner of the fighter in the kid
year
of course you know why cuz on the last
one I went and I [ __ ] stepped it up
they're like you want to come in and
[ __ ] and I was like yeah I'll come in
dude and I went for broke Theo came on
the [ __ ] I shut that [ __ ] down dude you
know why cuz I wanted to if you get me
in [ __ ] high activation mode dude
Mach 10 in that 99th percentile it's
over bro it's over I don't need a
[ __ ] haircut
congratulations on your haircut Thiele I
don't need a haircut I got that [ __ ] um
anyway I'm gonna close this [ __ ] out
okay there we go download download the
cash out for free on the App Store or
Google Play market text me eight one
eight two three nine seventy eighty
seven and Oh life rips well they were
[ __ ] restocked and then they went
away so they sell out so quickly you
guys I got another restock comment but
you guys got to be quick if you want it
I can't believe how many of these
[ __ ] hoodies are out there um anyway
that's good I'm gonna be in a Rama Rama
Ontario Aurelio Irvine is sold out pass
it Pasadena or wrestled out pasta yet
whoops excuse me I seen your brother um
Chris vidcom West Palm Beach I'll be
there
[ __ ] goodnight my babies
[Music]